and we're ready to give away good to
apply to the Defense Logistics Agency at
this way 800 number below we now return
to the military-industrial complex
awards and coveted Best Iraq bombing
camp it's often said that you can bomb
the world to pieces but you can't bomb
it into peace the finalists for our next
award beg to differ from Tomahawk cruise
missiles to Predator drones these
humanitarians have brought peace to the
very cradle of civilization no fewer
than four times in the past 25 years and
the nominees for the best Iraq bombing
are George HW Bush Allied air forces
began an attack on military targets in
Iraq and Kuwait
Bill Clinton their mission is to attack
Iran's nuclear chemical and biological
weapons programs George W Bush to disarm
Iraq to free its people and to defend
the world from grave danger
and Barack Obama we will conduct a
systematic campaign of airstrikes
against these terrorists and the winner
is Barack Obama this is President
Obama's first bombing war after a string
of nominations for military action in
Libya Somalia Yemen Pakistan Afghanistan
and Syria when we return the colon
Powell Award for Best Supporting Actor
you